remember Dragon Ball GT
[Music]
well this is its composer akihito
takunaga not the English composer and
well he isn't really a composer or at
least he wasn't when he was hired to
compose the music for the show at the
time he was just some bassist in bands
here and there literally zero prior TV
composing credits prior to GT and he
just gets chucked into the deep end on
one of the most popular anime of all
time how insane must that have been our
best guess for how he got that gig was
doing some songwriting for the band that
did GT's second ending but imagine just
being some guy in a band when suddenly
you are writing music for the Dragon
Ball guy must have had balls of steel to
accept that sort of a gig